mes grands parents avaient une
habitation de café et il tournait fait
eux-mêmes le café du jardin
donc j'ai toujours gardé en moi ces
odeurs du café ensuite je suis parti
après mes études universitaires pour un
voyage autour du monde où je me suis
formé auprès des meilleurs à la
torréfaction ma formatrice mon manteau
c'est vieillot casas qui est éthiopienne
et vice championne de france de
torréfaction de café
j'ai aussi appris avec une voix tu es
mal tech qui a fondé l'académie du café
en france
donc cette formation m'a permis durant
trois ans d'obtenir des diplômes
professionnels de d'artisans tous les
facteurs et de ballista sur le lien café
j'appartiens à cette nouvelle vague de
toutes les factions qui propose aux
clients une approche gastronomique du
café donc ce sont des cafés de
spécialité cueilli à juste maturité à la
main de la cerise jusqu'à la tasse donc
ce sont des cafés qui ont suivi un
processus entièrement naturel et en
harmonie avec l'environnement et l'homme
nous faisons venir ici les meilleurs
grains de café de spécialité donc ce
sont des cafés fin destiné aux amateurs
et aux chefs et ensuite nous avons aussi
un dans un deuxième temps un projet de
culture ou là nous essaierons de mettre
en place un café d'excellence mais qui
sera d'abord jugé par un jury
international parce qu'on ne peut pas
autoproclamé son café café d'excellence
il existe des organismes internationaux
qui certifie les cafés en fait je suis
pas assez de la salle de classe de
l'enseignant chercheur à l'artisanat et
donc c'est vraiment la réalisation d'une
passion qui a été possible grâce à la
famille al entourage amical